the clothes and we're live now on
Facebook how about that I swear lie once
again here we are with Judith Light a
very talented and Lifetime Achievement
Award winner congratulations I know -
I'm very honored um you had a lot of
great things to say in your acceptance
speech one of them that just kept
sticking with me and I actually wrote it
down was that the program was as
rigorous and exacting as theater itself
then at one point you realize that it
wasn't just theater it was life yeah
tell us a little bit more about that
well when I was coming here that's what
it said in the brochure it said this
program as this rigorous and exacting as
theater itself and one of the things I
said and when I was speaking tonight is
that I never forgot it and it's one of
the things that stayed with me forever
because when I came this was Carnegie
Tech it was not Carnegie Mellon
University you'll see in degree we set
up Carnegie thank you and what I was but
I was so struck by was the fact that
they were teaching us discipline and
they were teaching us perseverance and
they were teaching us all these
qualities that a lot of us had come into
the school with that we had our own
talent but we were living in a place
that the the mechanisms that we had
developed over time before we came to
the school were all about we're the most
talented in our community we're the
greatest one who's going to who's going
to make it you know when we're all of
you know 15 16 years old and what they
were doing was they were trying to teach
us about life and that was what the
thing that I realized that was the most
important and the most valuable to me
but it wasn't until I flipped it around
for myself that I said they're not just
talking to me about the theater they're
not talking to me about my career
they're talking to you about my life and
who I'm going to be and how I'm going to
be in the world
and what kind of person I'm going to be
and that became much more of the overall
context for me of my study here at Conte
and what an important lesson to this
being commencement weekend as well for
the soon to be alumni here now you also
said that you came here over the summer
because of theater educator a teacher
that you had yes my my Ruth strand was
her name and she was really supportive
of me she was also the head of the drama
club and I was president of the drama
club and this is in high school and she
said I'm reading this for sure and I
think you should go there and I think
you should study during the summer
between your junior and senior year and
she was actually right I mean it was one
of the most important things that I
could have done but it was because I had
a teacher who cared about me who took me
under her wing who nurtured me who
supported me and when you have arts
education what you end up having is the
learning about our society we learn
about our culture we learn how to
understand our psychology there are a
lot of young people out there who do not
have basketball or soccer or lacrosse or
swim team but they are in the art and
their art education is making available
to them a conversation changer it
changes not only the conversation but it
changes the culture and subsequently it
changes the world so we don't keep our
arts education I think we will be
diminished in many ways as a society I
absolutely agree we don't want to keep
you any longer but I just want everyone
we know Judith is such an amazing
actress but the things that you do for
the community for the LGBT community
fighting aids so important and we so
appreciate it thank you well the LGBTQ
community has been my inspiration on a
lot of levels because of the way that
they operated
from the highest level of human nature
during the height of the AIDS pandemic
this was a group of people who were
inspirational in the way they were
working and operating and dealing with
being treated as spoken about in ways
that were divisive and cruel and the
discount was so powerful to this
community and I watched the way they
operated and I watched people like
Elizabeth Taylor take on this mantle and
speak truth to power and say there are
two presidents who will not mention this
word and I watched the lesbian community
come to the aid of their their gay
brothers and I said I want to be working
in a community like that are we part of
that community and it's been a real
honor and a privilege for me to be a
part of that for such a long time and
they advocacy for that well thank you
very much for doing that thank you for
sitting down with us after relations
again thank you enjoy the rest of the
night Thanks